Can I Crack Neat If I Start Right Now
Yes Of Course Every Day Is A Fresh Start Every day after
waking up in the morning you have to decide
how you want to spend this day.
These 24 hours are yours. How you
want to spend it is you.  You will decide,
no one else will decide,
you will take your own decision,
no one else will, do you want to spend this whole day with full of
negativity or full
of positive environment, full of lot many things you can do
in your life, you can
read your topics.  You can do your mock test, you can
focus on the syllabus instead of just looking like wow, instead of getting into the hassle of results, it is
okay, now all the time
you spent in moe moe has been spent.
Now there is a strong need to be serious in the time that is left
and
you will get to see your change paper in 2024, so
obviously we need to prepare accordingly.